the olympics was awarded to tokyo
seven and a half years ago because it
was considered a safe
choice to say it's been a white knuckle
ride
since is an understatement sexism in the
organizing committee
a bribery scandal and now 100 days out a
pandemic still dictating the course of
events
trying to ignore this undercurrent of
controversy of the athletes
including this world champion and
leading gold medal hope
i'm not actually that engaged with the
news generally and i think that it
allows me just to stay focused on my
training and yeah
i know i wouldn't do anything
differently i'd still turn up to train
i'd still try and be the best athlete i
could be and whether or not the games
does it doesn't happen wouldn't change
that the athletes clearly want these
games to
happen the ioc want them to go ahead
because there's billions of pounds
riding on it
the japanese government want them to
happen because there's a certain amount
of national pride attached to them being
a success
but the overwhelming majority of the
japanese public
don't want to see this olympics happen
japan
only began vaccinating this week and
even without international fans
the olympics will bring tens of
thousands to the most crowded
metropolitan area on earth this summer
some experts can't believe it's actually
happening
japan is in the middle of so-called
fourth wave
of covet 19 so we do have a size of
increase in patients with kobe
i'm very pessimistic in holding
olympic games safely particularly when
people talk about inviting all the
audiences
domestically that will be extremely
dangerous
to have polls suggest between 70 and 80
of japanese people don't want the
olympics to happen
but defying that mounting resistance the
olympic mascots were unveiled to mark
100 days to go
the head of the british olympic
association says it's not a matter of
if it goes ahead but how they're taking
the measures that are necessary now
in order to enable the olympics to go
ahead safely in july
so i think the decision not to welcome
overseas spectators which would have
been very difficult for them because
you know that the economic boost you get
from tourism is one of the key arguments
for having an olympics
i think that is a reflection of the
nervousness in the host country quite
understandably
for many athletes this could be their
only opportunity to go to an olympics
many still don't know how they'll
qualify or prepare to compete
in a world of unknowns there is
uncertainty
that this will be a games like no other
martha kellner sky news